provenaient de matériaux m'avait dit
j'ai vu brejnev quoi j'ai vu bref il
était comme vous êtes devant moi en
aussi bonne forme il a fait un exposé et
son premier exposé a duré une heure une
heure et quart le redis ce que voulait
me dire reflète un peu ce que vous avez
entendu sur la lutte contre
l'impérialisme progression non c'est
sa veuve un franc que je discute avec
vous avec vous mais vous avez pas vous
n'auriez pas comme ça vous arrive on
n'en parle jamais vous arrivez pas vous
mettre dans votre petite tête que moi
aussi j'ai un cerveau et à c'est un mot
qui est capable de raisonner de
réfléchir et de formuler des
propositions et des appréciations tout
je suis pas bon je ne suis pas obligé
d'aller je ne vais pas apprendre mais
c'est ça c'est à l'image que j'ai dit
dans ma petite tête je me sens bien je
vais à l'étranger je discute j'écoutais
etc mais je suis quand même je sais je
suis peut-être qu'un ouvrière à vos yeux